flatulence or passing gas is a normal
daily phenomenon most individuals yes
that includes you will make anywhere
from 500 to 1500 milliliters of gas and
can pass gas 10 to 20 times a day but
where does this bodily gas come from a
small proportion may come from ingesting
air during sleep or at other times but
the majority of gas is produced by
bacteria in our intestines as they
digest parts of food which we cannot our
intestine is home to trillions of
bacteria living in a symbiotic
relationship with us we provide them
with a safe place to stay and food to
eat in exchange they help us extract
energy from our food make vitamins for
us like vitamin B and K boost our immune
system and play an important role in
gastrointestinal barrier function
motility and the development of various
organ systems clearly it's in our best
interest to keep these bacteria happy
gut bacteria get their nutrition
primarily from undigested food such as
carbohydrates and proteins which come to
the large intestine they ferment this
undigested food to produce a wide range
of compounds such as short chain fatty
acids and of course gases hydrogen and
carbon dioxide are the most common
gaseous products of bacterial
fermentation and are odorless some
people also produce methane due to
specific microbes present in their gut
but methane is actually odorless - well
then what stinks the foul smell is
usually due to volatile sulfur compounds
such as hydrogen sulfide and methane fel
or methyl mercaptan these gases however
constitute less than 1% of volume and
are often seen with ingestion of amino
acids containing sulfur which may
explain the foul smell of gas from
certain high protein diets increased
passage of gas is commonly noticed after
eating foods with high amounts of
indigestible carbohydrates like beans
lentils dairy products
onions garlic leeks radishes potatoes
oats wheat cauliflower broccoli cabbage
and Brussels sprouts humans lack the
enzymes so the bacteria able to ferment
complex carbohydrates take over and this
naturally leads to more gas than usual
but if you feel uncomfortable bloated or
visibly distended this may indicate
impaired movement of gas along the
gastrointestinal tract it's important
not to just blame certain foods for gas
and bloating and then avoid them you
don't want to starve the bacteria that
digest these complex carbohydrates or
they'll have to start eating the sugars
in the mucous lining of your intestines
your personal gas will vary based on
what you eat and what bacteria are in
your gut for example from the same
starting sugar the bacteria Clostridium
produces carbon dioxide butyrate and
hydrogen while Propionibacterium can
produce carbon dioxide propionate and
acetate at the same time methanogens can
use hydrogen and carbon dioxide produced
by other bacteria to generate methane
which can reduce the total volume of gas
by using up hydrogen and carbon dioxide
so there's a complex web among
intestinal bacteria allowing them to
flourish by either directly consuming
undigested food or using what other
bacteria produce this interaction
largely determines the amount and type
of gas produced so gas production is a
sign that your gut bacteria are at work
but in some instances people may develop
abnormal increased flatulence a common
example is lactose intolerance most
individuals have the enzyme for breaking
down lactose a sugar present in milk and
milk derived products but some people
either lack it entirely or have a
reduced amount such as after a
gastrointestinal infection so they're
unable to digest lactose products and
they experience cramping along with
increased flatulence due to bacterial
fermentation
remember most gas is produced as a
natural result of bacterial fermentation
in the intestine and indicates healthy
functioning of the gut the amount and
type can vary based on your diet and the
bacteria in your intestine exercise
social courtesy while passing gas and do
try to forgive your bacteria they're
only trying to be helpful